thank you alejandro yes we are indeed
with lanier dominguez lanier every time
i see you play against shanklin it's
just this crazy theoretical battle did
you expect that training for this game
uh not really i wasn't expecting the
line with d5 uh i thought sam was
playing mainly with d6 before this game
but it's of course a very direct line
very critical i was trying to remember
this line that we played because this
rook a8 is
pretty much the best move in this
position and and
um
i
i was analyzing and i i thought i had
some line i mean i thought i looked at
some line where uh maybe in practice it
was a bit tricky for for black i don't
remember if it was bishop d2 what i
played or not i was
uh trying to remember during the game
but i i
i don't know if this felt like the first
critical moment bishop to d2 or bishop
to g5 yeah i remember b75 being a knight
g4 uh and and then uh queen sequence
bishop c5 being
been the one of the main lines
but uh yeah i remember that there were a
couple of possible ways for white to
play
and uh
and uh yeah bishop d2 seems
seems like uh
like a possible option yeah here i think
uh yeah after knight g4
were you at uh at all concerned at this
point because he was just blitzing out
his moves he had one hour and 35 minutes
at some point and you only had one hour
in 20 minutes it felt like you were the
one that were surprised in this game
yeah no as i said i knew the line uh
that that's why i wasn't like overly
concerned i know that white is uh not
lost yet but uh
but uh yeah i uh obviously he he knew
the line well
and um that's why i didn't want to go
for bishop g5 because i know it was
supposed to be the main line i was
trying to find something else
but yeah unfortunately this uh after
bishop d2 knight g4 it's very logical
queen f1 and this knight e3 it's a
it's probably okay for black i know that
knight takes h2 and rook e5 or even
rookie 5 immediately it's should make a
draw yeah it's a draw by force but
it's maybe less obvious if you are let's
say playing over the world
but yeah after 93 takes takes knight g5
queen takes
takes on f2 and this queen is seven it's
important move because if you play
rookie 7 rook f1 then it's a little bit
unpleasant
but
but after queen e7 unfortunately
i didn't see much because just i mean if
rook f1 uh black can play guinea for but
also f6 you know
it's very simple at this point you did
understand that bishop takes f7 just
forces a draw right that was a big
decision uh did you consider other moves
such as rook to d1 rook to f1 try to
keep the game going and how did you
decide on bishop takes f7 and pretty
much kill the game yeah i thought that
uh black is
doing really well like in in the long
term it can be
um dangerous dangerous for white because
uh three pawns i mean if we were to
trade queens or something then i
definitely would take black
and
uh um
then also if i try to keep the queens my
king is always i mean he will always get
counter play with queen e4 check so i
don't really believe that uh
i had anything at this point that's why
i went for for bishop takes of seven and
i think objectively it's probably the
best decision
thank you very much and uh good luck in
tomorrow's game you're playing the black
pieces how are you going to approach
that game
yeah i mean it's uh just uh just normal
i mean clearly tomorrow it's a
much more important day than today we'll
decide the match but uh yeah i'm just
looking forward to not only the game of
tomorrow but just the rest of the
tournament
looking forward to seeing you in action
good luck and see you tomorrow thank you
good luck lanier and here